frank how old were you when you decided
you were going to go to film school
well i didn't actually go to film school
first
so i'm going to go back as far as seven
i got brought to manhattan by my parents
and i was from suburbia long island
and i remember walking down times square
and it was like nothing i'd ever seen
before
like smoke coming out of the sidewalks
people you know with boom boxes just all
that activity and energy
and i realized okay i gotta get out of
my small town and end up in new york
city
so when time came to pick out college i
was like i'm going to new york
i'm like that seems like the coolest
place on the planet it's like only two
hours away from where i grew up
and i applied to nyu at the time i
didn't know
movie making was an actual occupation i
loved movies i was from a very business
background family so
my sister said oh go for business like
okay apply for business
and i got into the business school
and i got there my first day to my dorm
got out of a cab
and there were students with film
cameras
making movies and i was like i didn't
know i could do that
i love movies so
i quickly enrolled in a film class
um and i think it was my first semester
and um
it was called film now i had this
amazing uh
teacher named nick tannis and
we would see movies there was a thursday
night class it was you'd see movies and
all week you'd see
shorts by the filmmaker and then you'd
see their feature films so we'd see like
shorts from gdard
and then we'd see breathless and we'd
see
like all the workings that went into the
way the director came to make his movie
and we'd study different movies like it
or different genres
um but the one moment that i think did
it for me was
i was what 18 17 18. i had not seen it's
a wonderful life by frank capra
and this teacher nick tannis said you
know i'm going to show
the movie tonight and then if anybody
wants to stick around it was thursday
night there was no class on friday in
college somebody got drunk
thursday night he said if anyone wants
to stick around and go through the movie
with a flashlight and tell you how the
director did certain things
so we watched the movie first time i'd
seen it
and you know frank capra one of my
favorite filmmakers
has been since that day uh it's a
wonderful life just touched me
moved me um was blown away and then when
the teacher said well anybody wants to
stick around
i'll show you why a director made
certain decisions i thought
a person made decisions to make me feel
this way literally it was that early on
in that i think when you grow up when i
did you didn't think about
there wasn't as much behind the scenes
making up the movies so you just went to
see a movie
so suddenly this whole idea of a person
was behind
you know making me feel these very
strong emotions that i felt like what a
great story
a great storyteller i sat through the
class and
i couldn't fathom how this man was a
genius and could do this
thanks to this teacher nick tennis and i
thought oh my god i have to figure out
how to do this and that was it i just
switched
full-on into filmmaking and it was
obsessed from that day on
to be able to try to touch people and i
i thought there's no way i could do this
when in that moment but i'm like but if
there's any small chance
i have to try did you see any parallels
between
it's a wonderful life and then growing
up was it sorry staten island long
island
sorry where did you grow up again oh
shirley long island shirley long okay is
that near i don't know
it's funny because it was far enough out
that people didn't commute to new york
city
unless they went to a concert and a lot
of people just go to a concert and get
back on the train
i pretty quickly was aware that like
that's the coolest city in the world i
think
so let me explore so i was going into
new york city at 15
16 you know going this is great you know
exploring
and then yeah that's why i ended up at
nyu to kind of i just knew there was
more
to learn about life and that new york
city would be the backdrop where i would
do that
did you see parallels between your own
life and it's a wonderful life and that
he didn't want to be stuck
working in this small town and he wanted
more
there was more adventure he wanted i
didn't at the time
see that i think it it grew on me
over time um but the bigger uh
thing about that movie that always
stayed with me was just
he spent his life being a good person
and being generous
and and he was at the point to literally
kill himself and and you know
through realizing how much he affected
everyone uh
it made his life worthwhile and i
thought if a movie
can like just make you in an hour and a
half
kind of live through a life a person's
experience
to have such a big change of heart and
thought about his whole life it's like
what a powerful
piece of art what a powerful
storytelling that it could actually
change somebody's life and you walk out
of the theater being like
i'm going to be more generous i'm not
going to count every penny that comes in
or goes out and
and so that that just that power is what
did it i wasn't so much the
small town thing maybe subconsciously
now now that you're saying it seems
really
apparent
do you remember the first time you met
adam sandler uh yeah very very well
um i was at nyu and um
i i had known him in the dorm because he
used to do stand-up at we had a thing
called the coffee shop the coffee house
it was like a variety show and i had
seen him and and just
the britney dorm small dorm in manhattan
um and i
only knew him just as hey that's adam
sandler and um
and my roommate said hey adam wants to
hang out with us tonight i know that's
cool he seems pretty cool
and him and tim and tim is tim hurley
who wrote a bunch of my movies and
most of adam's movies um so we hung out
we went out and had a typical college
night of uh
you know drinking and whatever and and
uh we lived in um
it was it was new york right so we lived
in this hotel it was our dorm room
and we were five to a room so what would
happen is if you got home really late
and your roommates were sleeping
we had these giant luckily we had these
giant closets
like like literally like walk-in closets
from an old hotel
so it was pretty common thing to if
you're up late keep the lights out going
the the closet with your friends so we
all had a great night of fun
made each other laugh all night and sat
in the closet all night and just made
each other
laugh and it's funny because when i was
in high school i
i i had a best friend that we had all
these sort of like funny
sounds and noises we make and i remember
thinking all right i'm off to college
that fun's going to be over but i'll
find a new kind of fun and then sure
enough my freshman year i meet adam and
tim and my roommate jack garpido
produced my movies
and uh there we are kind of doing what
you do in college smoking some weed and
making each other laugh
and uh and making bizarre noises
and that was just the beginning of us
saying man we're going to live
we said we'd live next to each other
every year across the hall and we did
and
and then while like we kept coming up
with funny ideas and we would write
comedy songs and
i was in film school and i would come up
with funny ideas and adam would be in my
short films and so we just started our
collaborative uh
creative process way back then yeah adam
would do stand-up
my senior year he's doing stand-up like
six nights a week so he would always go
and
instead of be a bouncing board to create
a bouncing board and
it was fascinating to see him go up on
the thing about stand-up is people go up
over and over to the point where you're
just bored of doing it
but you go up sometimes with a
half-baked idea
and just to see what you get back you
get kind of brave as a stand-up
and uh it would be interesting to see
some stupid idea that we thought oh my
god that tank
and two three weeks later it would be
the main part of his act you know like
elvis in the fridge or like some really
surreal stuff
um so yeah it was fun to be part of that
sort of coming up with his sort of
branding it was kind of our brand of
comedy which we
eventually brought to some of the movies
that we did together do you remember any
of the tv shows or films that you would
maybe watch
together or just say we want to do stuff
like this the funny thing is i was like
we always i went to nyu thinking i just
want to do
little art weird out there
movies and adam was great because those
are the movies he would love to go to
see with me
like basquiat he loved like all these
little indies were the ones that he
responds to it's funny he he would go
see a lot of comedies
and he would get bored and walk out even
though he wanted to do comedies and i'm
like
i want to do these kind of like cool
edgy push the envelope
and uh um yeah so i i just remember more
of like
you know like we saw blue velvet and it
was like nothing else we'd seen i think
what attracted me and and him is seeing
movies that
tonally did things that's the thing
about
a movie that you can create that that's
hard to do in a book or other mediums
um i guess now you can do on tv is
create a different tone i think like
quentin tarantino's success is
he mixed violence with comedy in a way
nobody had at the time
and his tone is very different and and
it's that's you know when you think of
just straight dramas
they start to become very similar but
once you start to get into
either you know comedy is usually where
it becomes more about the tone uh you
know there's a million different kinds
of comedies
and and and some could be dark and some
could be satirical and some could be
you know just every version some could
just be really in your face stupid and
slapstick
um and you start to realize i i
at first i was like critical like i
don't want to do comedy i would do
comedy and then the more
i was analyzing what i was doing and
seeing movies i realized
so much of it is tone and then so much
you can affect tone with
irony and and all these things that have
to do with humor
um i had a moment where i was like
looking at my dog one day i was kind of
stoned
and uh and i was thinking that's my dog
i can i can he gets
he gets happy he gets sad he he
can he i can scare him um but i can't
make him laugh
i jump around the corner i do something
and he would just never
and i'm like well he definitely can't
get irony so i
at that point it was when i was first
making i was somewhere around the
wedding single warded boy
and i was being a little critical of
like i didn't want to make comedies
i had this revelation that i go what
other animals laugh
and then i was like well dolphins i
guess kind of laugh
and like monkeys and gorillas and i'm
like in humans and i'm like
maybe i shouldn't be so critical that
i'm making comedies because it takes
intelligence to understand
humor not to take anything away from a
drama but
there's more levels of nuance and
subtlety
that go into comedy so i feel better now
that i've made comedies
even though my most recent movie is more
of a drama
who had bigger dreams at that point you
were adam
i think we had a very similar quest to
do
something important
i my mom always gave me the feeling that
like you could
you know believe in yourself you can do
whatever you need to
do and um when i said i was gonna make
films i got nervous
my dad all he knew was the godfather and
he said you're going to be a director
the mafia is going to own you because
all they can think about is the horse's
head in the bed
and i'm like no dad they they they don't
really do that that's only in the movies
they just have the teamsters
[Laughter]
but i just had uh big goals and adam
always
since i met him wanted to be the
funniest man on the planet
and uh and so his drive was very strong
to do that
um uh so in a good way it overlapped i
you know
my thing was i just wanted to tell
i felt like i had i felt like things
were obvious to me
like like greed is bad and all these
people in the 80s are being really
greedy and they're being money hungry
and
it was just really apparent to me that
was an empty an empty fulfillment if
you're just
going for the money like in my head it
was like oh it's about how you get the
money it's about don't you want to
create something or
and and so i realized i have an insight
that not everybody has
and then when i the idea of making
movies and how powerful they were i
thought
if i could figure this out i can
hopefully tell stories
that are worth telling because i always
go back to
how much as a kid movies shape who you
are
it's like you have your parents and you
have whatever
religion you're brought up but at the
end of the day i think movies have a
massive massive effect on on on who you
become and
your sense of right and wrong your sense
of who a hero is your sense of you know
what's yeah
it just really sets up so many mores a
young age
when i think about making my movies a
lot of them have been
for a small a younger audience like kids
it's super important to me to think
about you know
a kid going to see a movie with his
parents or alone or when they're hanging
out with all their buddies how it's
going to affect them so
i've definitely embraced especially when
i was making some of the
more fun comedies like the water boy and
it's like like they're bullying the kid
and i thought
this is i'm doing something good even
though they seem like just pure
entertainment and it's just dumb
there's a real story there's real hard
they're real characters i always try to
anchor
my characters in real people even though
the water boy was kind of
a big over-the-top movie at the end of
the day me and adam we chose to play
him like a real guy like like rain man
except some of the choices we make are
silly when he tackles he made
crazy noises but he he's the reality
that i create in my movies i try to keep
totally real so that
i try to keep true to the reality you
set up it doesn't shift
so once you're in that world you believe
that world and then
you invest in the characters and my
thing is i want to make movies that even
though they're comedies
when they are comedies in the third act
you really are hooked in your seat
where a lot of comedies sort of fall
apart in the third act because the
stakes don't really matter um so that's
i know i'm not a tangent but
i'm just kind of rambling but yeah
stakes having a reality that's
believable
with stakes that you care about to me is
a really important part of telling a
story
well going back to the topic of greed
how did
you know how the term yuppie was sort of
coined in the 80s and sure
all the gentrification going on in new
york city probably around that time yeah
exactly
yuppies bmws all that yeah right a lot
of people being forced out of apartments
and things like that
did that growing up as a kid and seeing
some of that did that shape you at all i
know you were
more on well it's funny when i think of
the movie i just did now is all about
how polarized we are and how we
shouldn't be
and in a weird way it was the beginning
of us being a little bit polarized
it's funny because in my dorm i had like
weird art i found on the street and my
roommate uh who went on to be
um pretty stark republican had
um ronald reagan as a cowboy alf
a poster of money and a bottle of jack
daniels but
um but at the time it was
i'm going to get into the polarization
it was like you can
have different things you lean towards
but we could all talk
and and what's really hard for me right
now and
i do want to talk about because it's
super important to the movie i think i
might have made one of the most
important movies i've made
thus far is since 9 11 i've been seeing
the world just got really polarized not
just i travel like
a lot i thought first it was in our
country every country is super polarized
people are going
far right far left um
and it's getting very tribal and
it's losing everything that i think
that's important to me the most
important things are honesty
and integrity and i think in the
hope to fight for your side people are
willing to look the other way
at things that are wrong they're willing
to lie they're willing to
embellish the truth and i think when
that happens
we're just going to fall apart as as you
know as a civilization and
i am super worried about that um
because i do think that it's irrational
uh where we're allowing irrational
behavior
where we're not um making people
accountable for when they do something
wrong
and you know if you talk about like
whatever in politics it's like
if you say well donald trump it's not
right that he did that and instead of
saying
yeah it's not right you shouldn't do
that they go but hillary did that
it's like it they're two separate
stories maybe what he did was wrong and
maybe what hillary did was wrong
the point is we need to focus on what's
right and wrong
um and so that has just gotten worse and
worse and
i love technology i think the internet
has the ability it had the it sort of
backfired on us
just in that people are losing empathy
for each other
because when we sit across from each
other and have an argument
and i say something and i see your
emotion and i see you are hurt
i will as a human being react to that
and be like wow that wasn't really right
when they said that was a little bit
crazy
on the internet there's no face and
people
tend to just not listen to the other
side they just want to get out what they
want to say
and it just gets meaner and meaner and i
love technology and i wouldn't want to
take it away
i just think we need to evolve as humans
to be more empathetic without seeing
someone's face
and be more open to the fact that we may
be wrong sometimes and
ultimately just be to be more effective
like we need to listen to each other and
and not get so polarized and
the 24-hour news cycle didn't help that
um
and it's gotten just worse because you
know
whichever way you lean it seemed like
fox started from my perspective
and then i i i watch a lot of the new
shows i've always watched and
it's so reactionary now that it's almost
escalating
and it's like i just kind of wish it was
just the news
uh just facts and and and and
yeah it's been concocting this crazy
world and and it's hard to go home
during um the holidays and and sit
around the table with
people that have opposite opinions we
literally in my home
have brought up like no politics at the
table i'm smart
sometimes we go into it and then it's
like we all go all right we love each
other
let's not talk about that so i the movie
i just made
is called hot air i was had this idea
for a while in my head
and um that we need to fix this and
um a script got sent to my manager and
she sent it to me uh aleetri
and it was uh called hot air and my
producing partner amy keane read it
and she was like wow frank this is what
you've been talking about
but it's a beautiful little small story
uh and she knew i wanted to go back and
make an indie because
my first movie was an indian we can get
into that a little bit um
and i read this story and it was a
beautiful story about
just a small family drama it just
happened to be that
the lead was a right wing talk show host
ala
you name you know rush limbaugh whoever
um
and his niece comes into his life that
he had never met from his estranged
sister who he hated
and um she's about to go into foster
care because
her mom's gonna go into rehab and she
sort of inserts herself in his life and
he wants to have nothing to do with her
and she's as clever as him and says well
if you
uh put me back in the foster care you're
gonna i'm gonna tweet a message saying
you're putting me back into the social
services that you rag on all the time
you know and then he realizes this niece
is really smart and the movie's about
the two of them going head to head
and you know it's not like at the end of
the movie he becomes a liberal
and you know but by the end of the movie
he becomes a better human
by listening to her and everyone in the
movie shifts just
a little bit and they're able to
communicate and and that
the goal of the movie was to make a
movie that you can see this movie with
your
republican or your liberal or your
conservative family
and you can all go together and you can
come home and be like
all right i'll listen to what you have
to say this time so i
it seems to have been getting that kind
of response it's coming out this weekend
so
i'm excited to see if it affects people
in the way that i
hope it does even if it's a few people
it'll be great did you used to watch a
lot of the 90s talk shows
do you remember like somebody would get
up in front of geraldo or jerry springer
and it was calm for a little bit and
then the first one
and through the first rock and then it
was awesome i kind of was like one of
those guys that was
like anti that you were yeah yeah but i
i found them fascinating and uh i just
remember story because um juliette lewis
had done a movie with adam and
she used to watch them all day and just
imitate people and then you realize how
she's so good at doing that
just a little offshoot a little side
shoot um
yeah i wasn't a big fan of those shows i
i they just kind of bugged me because i
felt like they were just
cashing in on people's um they're just
pushing buttons and
you know and it was like watching a
train crash you can't turn the other way
but i was able to turn the other way
so that wasn't my thing i love letterman
oh yeah
i love things like that he was not i
liked that he was not always soft on
everyone
that's true i always liked that he would
either like somebody and be cool with
them
and if he didn't like them he would he
wouldn't needle him a little yeah
yeah but he would do it with with a
little bit with class yeah and
dignity and all those nice things yeah
right yeah i just was curious
if the sort of the evolution of those
those talk shows has now turned into
people in comments and and how i think
it is
you know it all goes back to me to
integrity
it's cause like you read a headline and
it's like the headline is just
to like exacerbate something or just
inflame
and and you realize they just want to
click and it's it's we're in this just
get do anything for attention
even at the expense you know like
sometimes the headlines just misleading
and then the misleading headline becomes
what everybody talks about and creates
rumors
you know i mean it's like so i just
think people have to have integrity
if you just that's the bottom line
integrity includes honesty
and you know uh treating people fairly
it's like
if everyone had integrity it would be
such a nicer world and and we
used to have more and we're having less
now it was never perfect
and we're always a work in progress um
but i feel like this whole idea of
being a work in progress is is almost
thrown out the window i mean
i'm going to just tangent into guns and
it's like we have all these problems
with people
wanting gun control and other people
saying well they're going to take guns
away and
and like look it's never going to be
perfect but we have a problem
and what always made america a great
country is we would work on fixing the
problem
you know i i think it was like trevor
and i were talking about like we had
problems with cars so then you put
you know you make people wear seat belts
and you create rules and like and that's
what made this country great
and and i feel like now we're not
willing to even because people taking
such sides we're not even willing to
work on fixing it even if it's baby
steps and and
and that's you know i get i'm getting
into all these social issues because i'm
a filmmaker and
it's starting to become so important uh
to me that we start fixing some of these
things because i just feel like
it doesn't feel like it's gonna be a
great world in 20 30 40 years and
i don't have kids yet i want to have
kids and my friends have kids and i'm
just like i
want to do it for them
sometimes you can show your side of
something doesn't mean you change
someone's opinion but with humor
so if you show someone a documentary
that's clearly biased people are gonna
oh well this filmmaker just you know
this is the lobbyist paid him to do you
know these different things but
humor is a very effective way of getting
people to kind of let down their guard
and maybe for one moment entertain
something whether it's their own fault
in something or just seeing something in
a different light
yeah so that's one thing you know here's
it's funny this is a blueprint for
storytelling
and it's not quite humor but it what's
great about
really great storytelling if you think
of and i've used this as a model in some
of my movies
to kill a mockingbird to me in so many
ways is like
brilliant storytelling and and and i'll
explain pretty simply why
in this bunch of the only book she wrote
right then the movie's great
um the movie's about racism
and there's uh i remember while there's
a um
a young black fellow who's being tried
for something he didn't do
and it as a viewer of the audience
you're thinking how could these people
be so
biased and racist and and and you're you
just
can't fathom it right the subplot in the
story is
the kids have a neighbor boo radley
and they're sort of totally afraid he's
the boogeyman
and as the story unfolds and the
audience
is super afraid of him and you're like
horrified of this boo radley guy
and you're thinking man this is kind of
crazy but that guy's you know
evil for sure by the end of the movie
he ends up being the sweetest man
possible and i thought
well that's brilliant filmmaking because
you look at them and go how could they
be racist towards this
young black kid meanwhile asked the
audience you were racist
towards this guy boo radley because you
didn't know enough about him
and it was the ignorance and and to me
that's like perfect storytelling
we were actually sucked into being
racist and now we can suddenly relate to
why other people can be racist
and it has to do with ignorance and it's
just those layers is like what makes
storytelling amazing and
you know you can do it even more in
movies with with those kind of layers
but
you know it all starts with the writing
and then it comes to the next level
which is the
which is the movie um for me that's the
way i look at it obviously books
stand on their own um yeah so um i don't
know how i got that tangent but that
that's sort of a model it's my major
movie around the world in 80 days
and i used that sort of template i
wanted the movie be about
travel and how it opens you up because
i've traveled my whole life and
and i think a lot of americans didn't
travel enough and the more you travel
the more you get more
you know tolerant and understanding of
other cultures and suddenly not fearful
and it just makes you a better person it
makes you
more well-rounded and in the story
phillius fogg is an inventor
and he's up against the royal academy of
science and they believe that everything
that could be invented
has already been invented and he thinks
how could these guys be so pig-headed
and and and not believe this and he gets
in this adventure to go around the world
meanwhile he in his own right is really
big-headed
and close-minded and isn't open to art
and all these other things
but he goes on this journey around the
world he meets jackie chan plays
passport two he meets a french artist
he he doesn't even know what art is and
he thinks it's crazy and stupid in a
waste of time
by the end of the movie he becomes a
full-rounded person
he gets to fully realize his dream that
a man can fly
and he they uh wins tibet on a flying
machine i embellished the original book
and movie
and to me it was the same i used um
uh um to kill a mockingbird in that
make him see them as one way and then
realize he himself was as
as closed-minded as they were so that
kind of like double layer thing is a
great
device that you can use in storytelling
and
so yeah i i like that kind of stuff when
this layer is
going on like that did you work any day
jobs
while you were either at nyu or
afterward yeah okay when i was at nyu
i i was very cool and still is i guess
but um there was probably a lot more
than a
vintage clothing store i was a new wave
kid
it was cool to live in manhattan and i
worked at a place called the antique
boutique
and i didn't get paid very much i don't
want to say how much because it'll show
all day
and it was like 350 an hour believe it
or not
um i did that because my dad was paying
for my college and i felt like i wanted
to work
during school um uh and then
soon after school i did anything i could
to work
in film in any way and that's the advice
i give to kids is like
if you're gonna have to take a job even
if don't make it be about the money at
first
unless you're really lucky um i worked
literally as a pa on commercials
i just was excited to be on set to see
how a real set worked but really
what i had to do was drive a cube truck
around pick up c-stands
get really greasy and dirty and you know
get the food
table ready and all that stuff but i
kind of feel like
i learned from the bottom up how things
run
and i was a really good pa um and then
the difference then and now as you get
you go to film school and you get to
direct a movie
it's like the ultimate privilege to
um once you graduate you're like oh my
god
i don't have cameras i don't have film
um it's not like now with
iphones and and you can edit on your
iphone and your laptop
so all i did was want to get to a job
where i could have equipment
so one of the next jobs i took was um
while i was pa and i ended up getting
the opportunity to work for shy at day
advertising
i was in new york so there wasn't a lot
of i wasn't in
uh uh introduced to the movie world so i
would work on commercials because that's
what was going on in
the early 90s late 80s
um i got to edit reels and stuff and
then i got to use the editing equipment
and then i had a camera so we would
go and shoot shorts and then on the
weekend and then we'd film them
and then from that job i parlayed that
into doing travel documentaries this
travel company
had sent actually jack perez it's funny
you interviewed him
had done the first one for this travel
company i believe it was jack
and they did one and didn't want to do
another one i saw this opportunity
to um travel i was like oh my god i'm 22
23. i can travel the world i can direct
the funny thing was we were directing a
video for a bus tour like a bus group
tour so it was
literally a lot of silver-haired people
fluent yeah but i was super excited to
travel
australia new zealand all over the world
and
for me it was it was getting to film to
direct
i was shooting i was a director but i
would also shoot and then we would um
edit the pieces together and it was just
going through the process from beginning
to end
and it's funny i think about these
travel documentaries that were
given to people to go in the bus stores
and we would have
heated arguments about
four four frames on an edit
i think back when i'm like making
features like we used to fight over just
these stupid travel dog
but it's that same kind of application
of like you really want it to be great
um that you just keep doing um but so
yeah
i did that and uh yeah which leads me to
say like kids always ask me like are
students not kids but they're like
what you know what should i do and i'm
like i wish
when i got out of film school that i had
a hd
camera and you have one in your hand and
and
the the most learning you ever do in
filmmaking
is not starting a film it's finishing a
film so
it's so hard because when you first
start what you have in your head and
what you get
unless you're a prodigy there's a big
difference of what you want and what you
get
so then getting to the end and editing
it ends up being really painful
because you're like you imagined it to
be this and the shot's not that it's not
lit the way you wanted in the
camera but by getting to the end you
have to finish it the learning curve is
so great
by finally getting done and it's so
painful
that that's when you learn everything so
the second time you do it you really
don't make
those mistakes you make a whole set of
new ones but you've just got a whole
bunch of knowledge
um and and i just tell people go out
write a story don't don't beat yourself
up just have fun
write a story get your friends together
you don't even need to spend a lot of
money
and film it and i'm shocked now because
i think of movies like um
was in ed burns made brothers mcmullen
he did his credit cards and i think for
like whatever was 15 30 grand
he made this movie on 16 millimeter and
a guy had a great career and he made a
bunch of films and
he became an actor i'm shocked now that
there's not this and there's so many
places to play your movie
i don't know why more people aren't
going and shooting a
feature-length film you can make it for
nothing you make it for a grand or you
know borrow 500
even if you want as long as you got time
on your hands
and edit that thing if you can afford an
iphone or borrow one
edit it and put it on youtube and if
it's a really good movie there's no
reason somebody can't make a really good
movie
some of the most amazing things you do
are when you're really young as a
filmmaker because you're fearless
so i just i recommend people just keep
making start with shorts
and and and and keep working your way to
make a feature film if you really want
to make a film now you can
and you can find an audience i wonder
how much
of something being forbidden makes you
love it more because i remember also
seeing cameras in the sears catalog
i'm old enough to remember this year's
catalog and they were way too expensive
there was no way
i could ever have one but i kept looking
at the page thinking if i had that what
would i be doing
because it was forbidden to me it became
more special
yeah so i just wonder having so much
access
does that almost hurt it well something
like any constraints
constraints deadlines make us better
it's like just a human nature is if you
don't have a gun to your head
you learn to self-inflict the gun but
you don't make it a gun
you just get yourself to sit down and do
the work it's like
writing when you think about it it's
like is you have you have no constraints
you can write about anything
and and sometimes that's the hardest
script to write it's like when somebody
says you have to write something with
three characters has to take away from
one
house and one the minute you start
putting walls and constraints
is the minute you start getting ideas so
it's a lot more
you have to self um discipline yourself
when there's no constraints so i think
that's the reality but
i hope when i say this like go and make
a film make a short film i hope
some people do i know there's a lot of a
lot of people make short films for sure
but then i think they realize how hard
it is and it's hard to have the gumption
to
to make a full feature length because
it's a long and grueling um
task and there's no you know it's like
if you have somebody giving you the
money and
distribution deal well then there's a a
a motivating goal
but i think if you could self-motivate
you can become
you could be nobody and if you have an
iphone you can become a great filmmaker
and you'll eventually get hired
have you always been a self-starter i
always try but i you know
i like any creative person you wrestle
with like i think i'm being lazy i think
i'm
i still haven't done my movie and then i
spent time with paul tom and sanders and
we were in hawaii because adam knows him
well and we're friends
um great director right one of my
favorites and i remember him sitting
there going i still haven't made my
movie
and i'm like you're saying that and i
was like oh good if you're saying that
then at least i know i don't feel as bad
about myself saying that
so so i think this the tortured artist
is
you don't think yourself started but
obviously we've gotten ourselves this
far
so you know but you have to
self-motivate and and
the best reward is when you do it you
feel great and when you don't do it you
feel miserable
right and then this inertia sets in with
everything exactly
exactly yeah
is film making an addiction it's for
making an addiction
oh that's a tough one i
couldn't do anything else i i feel like
you know like if i read they might hear
people retiring i'm like i've never
retired i'm just gonna make films until
i can
until they stop i think it's a privilege
so it's less addiction for me and it's
more privileged and i
don't every time i make a film i don't
want
that privilege taken away so i'm super
grateful that i get to make movies
and think about you like hey everybody
come into my brain people are going to
give me millions of dollars or
a million dollars or many millions
they're giving me all these talented
people and what i have in my brain
i get to show to a bunch of millions of
people
so it's like it's a privilege to get
that and and and i i
feel that way every day uh it's not an
addiction but it's something i would
never
not do how's that how do you know
you wouldn't be i mean i know you said
you worked at a used clothing store and
you were like this new waiver
that sounds a rock star would be another
thing i'd like to be
because but david that's much more about
your own fulfillment because i mean you
know you see a rock star on the stage
and
oh yeah and all these women and that'd
be great but i don't think i would be
still alive if i did that
and uh i think i i think honestly music
could give a lot to people but
sure um there's something about
filmmaking that
just sits well with me it's like it's
very it takes a lot of thought and
premeditation a lot of layers to it and
and
um i the other thing i do for fun is i
dj
and i think the reason i do that is
because film's so premeditated
and the other two things i do is dj and
cook they're both like
writing cooking's like riding a wave you
have to do it at the moment
you know it's not premeditated as much
and and djing's like
immediate reaction play music people
respond you react to them
um i find it fascinating i went to go
see the movie time
code a few years back by mike figgis and
there's this brilliant idea you had that
there would be four screens and all the
actors had
literally a watch with time code and he
choreographed almost like a live play
um where everybody had to do a certain
thing at a certain time it was a
fictional story he created with you know
drama and
arguments and i can't remember those
shootings or anything um
like sama hai goes in a bunch of great
actors and
uh they probably did a number i think he
said they did 13 or 14 takes
because there was one take when you
finally saw the movie and everything was
choreographed that like somebody would
leave that room and end up
on the street and all the cameras are in
different places
and i thought well that's fascinating
and then when i went to see it
mike figgis um i sent the new art
theater here in la
uh mike figgis actually live mixed um
the four stories and he said it for him
it was fascinating because
normally the movie went out without the
mix and and he would raise and lower
different
stories but by actually being in the
theater depending on
how he felt the audience was responding
he would raise the volume more
he would kind of guide the people a
little bit to where they were
going and i just thought that's such a
cool element to add to filmmaking if
there's a way to make it like
interactive for the director that you
can change it um
uh i i don't know it just was a
fascinating thing because again movies
are so premeditated you sort of do it
and then
you put it out there and that's it um i
do find tv
is something i want to do because i um
went to school with vince gilligan
at nyu and he created one of the best tv
shows i think
breaking bad and when i started to hear
him talk about it
jesse pinkman who ends up being kind of
the main
sort of the co-main character and
eventually becomes sort of the
moral point of view of the audience he
was supposed to die in i think the first
season or halfway to the first and i i
think it's fascinating in tv that you
you have this living thing that you're
like oh people are liking jesse and hit
and and they start to even see between
them the the creative people
seeing what's working and the audience
responding
it becomes its own thing and i
i'm fascinated my next step is to get
involved in
in cable tv i always go like where did
all the edgy 70s movies going i go they
went to cable
they're our tv now um so that's that's
an exciting
thing yeah and it's interesting gauging
the audience's reception because i've
been
in some movies as an audience member
where i'm the only one laughing
and it's a little bit disconcerting
because then i think well i guess i have
to kind of tone it down
and then i went to see the my mike
wallace documentary
and most people they were probably 20
years older than myself and they were
loving it and then i felt free i could
like laugh and and
but then you i went to see vice and no
one was you know
it was total silence and sometimes it
depends on the area
yeah you see the fact that definitely
the area even the time
that's true when you're when you're
actually popping my head in theaters
sometimes
yeah and then we also do previews of our
movies a lot and and uh
yeah a late audience if they're drunk
it's one thing
but different regions will react
differently different
economic levels yeah we'll laugh at
different things for sure
um yeah so it is interesting when you're
making a movie because you can't make
everybody happy
um but i guess you got to make sure you
make yourself happy and then hopefully
you get a lot of people in there with
you
sure and one i saw in the suburbs and
the other one i saw
in more of a city area and so there was
a difference in reaction and
it's interesting to see two who claps
after movies
as well yeah i i gotta say that one
one of the greatest greatest feelings
not as much as being a rock star and
going
but i i will sneak into a theater and
and see how my movie's doing in the real
world and like you premiere obviously
people are going to clap because they
know you're there
but i've had i've watched my movie
playing people applaud
and it's such a great feeling because
you're like are they paid to see my
movie and they're applauding
so that that fulfillment is it makes it
all worthwhile it makes all the hassle
and all the
hard stuff that goes along with
filmmaking so worthwhile
was this an industry town where you saw
this uh
were they clubs different places oh wow
i've done it
uh but it was definitely regular people
it wasn't just people in the industry oh
no no
it was like people on a saturday
afternoon i went to see my you know i
think it happened with
um around the world in 80 days for sure
uh click
for sure um yeah yeah
it's fun you do all that work you kind
of want to pop your head in though and
then
see how it's playing right and not have
it where they're performing for the
director
yeah yeah no it's a true test it's scary
sometimes you're like why aren't they
laughing that joke they laughed at the
previews
you're writing stuff down like there's
this guy in the back writing everything
down
who's that joke
your first film or feature film was
murdered innocence burning innocence
it's kind of like i lost my virginity on
it okay okay she called you afterwards
not literally oh okay all right i lost
my innocence
okay got you yeah it was funny i was um
i was i had made short films i had made
a thing with adam i did a short
adam sandler because he was i was he was
at snl and i had this reel i put
together of
just anything and everything i could
shoot i had a psa
and uh and i was i was obsessively
trying to put this reel together because
i thought the real was going to be the
way
that i get to be a filmmaker
i had in my head from being at nyu that
all my favorite filmmakers
scorsese coppola spielberg like everyone
had made a movie before they were 30.
and
i had this like self-inflicted i have to
do it
oh that's it i'm not going to make it
and i literally was in the editing room
like 20 hours and i had some weird
visual reaction
seizure thing and i got rushed to the
emergency room
and while i was in the hospital i sat
there and i thought
the dumbest thing i've ever thought was
like that there's a number i go if i'm
really a filmmaker
i don't care if i'm 40 50 60 70. i'm
never gonna stop
until i make movies and it was almost
like i had to have that revelation
because the following week i was on long
island with my girlfriend at the time
in a video store i think was a
blockbuster they were still around
and uh i turned the corner and this guy
is hitting on my girlfriend
and he's like i'm a filmmaker and then
movies and and
i'm like yeah i'm a filmmaker too he's
like yeah what did you do i go
you want to see my reel he's like yeah
i'll see you real and then he saw my
reel and he had it was this guy fred
carmen who had made a bunch of indies on
long island
and uh he goes yeah you're good man um
hey you wanna you wanna direct this
movie you have 14 days and we have like
you know two hundred thousand dollars
i'm like
can i read the script i'm like yeah so i
read the script and it was just like
really bad police drama
and i'd seen his other movies and they
were kind of these weird bee
movies one was gary bergdoff as a serial
killer your transvestite zero killer i
thought
it's kind of cool my first opportunity
to make a weird movie
i read the script it was all like police
talk
but kind of like corny tv police talk
so i i called up one of my buddies um
from nyu steve
perros and i read the script i get to
make this movie but the script is not
good at all
and they go well you rewrite it i'm like
yeah and i'm like see what you think and
then he goes well you love phil noir
and i'm like yeah it's like this kind of
corny dialogue
can be easily shifted to like noirish
kind of dialogue and it had this whole
flashback of
uh murder that happened in the 70s and
so we we whole i said i'm gonna rewrite
you guys you have two weeks to rewrite
it
we rewrote it um and uh we had jason
miller
was cast in it who was the priest and
the exorcist he was nominated for that
he also wrote that championship season
beautiful man
he passed away a few years back um he
loved what i did with the script it had
a lot of depth
it was a dark dark story i think we had
a 17 body count
by the end of the movie oh wow it had to
have that i
had to kill a bunch of people i had to
blow up a car and so we made the story
with the parameters that the producer
wanted
and the other parameter was the producer
had to be the lead
oh wow okay and so we rode a roll that
you know we kind of made him under his
breath
and then he blows up and gets angry and
and and i
kind of we put together a movie that was
kind of kind of weird and cool
very blue velvet influence because i had
seen that at the time so it was quirky
weird
talk about tonally strange movie um and
um
you know i didn't get to cast everyone i
wanted it was like the visual effects
the special effects guy had to be the
bad guy
so the level of talent was a little bit
all over the place so
because i knew that i played it a bit
campy again
with blue velvet as an inspiration and
so it was this weird dark
uh kind of funny uh movie um
which has one of my favorite final shots
in it
because i was a huge fan of the graduate
and
my favorite last shot of that movie is
he finally gets the girl
and the two of them are in the back of
the bus and and mike nichols is
brilliant because he just leaves
the camera on them till it just gets
uncomfortable
and this home in my movie they're
they're doing all the stuff running
killing
and they finally get away the girl and
the guy
and the camera does this creepy just
pull back and inspired by
by mike nichols shot and and it's just
like okay now they have each other now
what
um but yeah i got to make this cool
movie and the first time you make a
feature film you think
something about if you really want to be
a filmmaker
the scariest thing in the world is to
make a feature film because you could
think how can i hold all this in my head
um and i did it and i was like this is
cool and then columbia tristar had seen
it these days of home video
and they bought it immediately and they
got one type of home video
i don't think it's available on blu-ray
or anything now but uh it would be great
if it was
i i just got honored in the festival in
switzerland then they showed it
so that was the first time i'd seen it
in years in front of an audience
it was dubbed in german
it seemed to go over pretty good
so so you literally got this job by
being at a blockbuster video
yeah and having a hot girlfriend i guess
yeah that helps so did you believe
it what going back it was fred carpenter
yeah and that's what it was so
did you believe him at that point like
when he was yeah i think i
my i was i was in my hometown my parents
had showed me an article
hey look at this because i was in film
you know i came out of film school look
at this guy in our town
it was like an expose in newsday or
something
and so i i knew i kind of knew a small
town i grew up in i was like oh yeah
that's that guy
[Laughter]
yeah and then you co you then
helped reshape the script yeah and the
funny thing is
is so i had like i didn't even have a
real crew we had like
um a guy who did like our gaffer did
like um
industrials you know this is out long
deep long island
and um uh the crew was all hofstra
students
and they were like first second year
students they didn't even have the
equipment that i had at nyu so they were
like
really green um and but i'm i'm good at
rallying the troops and getting them to
believe in the movie and
our 14-day shoot went for like 38 days
because i got people to work for free
for me and
you know but like i bought more film it
was like that kind of thing where like i
used my credit cards and
you know i didn't take any money i think
i was supposed to get paid money to
direct it and i just
put that into the film and yeah lenny
weintraub was
this investor he was a real really sweet
real estate guy
and he invested in the movie and was
excited to be
part of hollywood we weren't quite
hollywood then but there were some real
actors
ellen green she was a theatrical actor
she was in the movie
she was in like little shop of horrors
on broadway then or
around that time yeah so we just we just
pulled it pulled it off she cut it on
film
my editor um tom lewis has edited most
of my movies
he had my film school buddy um
yeah the guy who was a cinematographer
on my
travel documentaries was the
cinematography first there was a bunch
of nyu people came together to help me
out
so it goes to home video how long before
then you get your next job which is the
wedding
so meanwhile adam was having his career
was going in a really good way
and um i was determined not to come to
la without a movie because i knew
everybody was a director
and and adam had seen the movie and
loved it and i remember um
he had his agent see it and they're like
that's cool
you know and the fact that i did a movie
got him couldn't wait for me to direct
his movies
he had done i think billy madison by
then
he called me up and said i'm working on
a comedy album
you already made your movie come to la
come for two weeks and help me with the
comedy album
and it was an album called what the hell
happened to me so i wrote on a bunch of
skits i acted on some of them
and then um i did a music video
for one of the songs with steve
polychronopolis it's kind of a precursor
to the wedding singer because it was an
80s bully but it was all about 80s
wardrobe stonewashed pants and
and the bi-level haircut and i shot this
video and i didn't realize like
all eyes because adam was just starting
to really excel
every big wig in town came to see who's
this frank karachi guy directing the
video and
i'm just loving it because i'm getting
like real equipment and
you know and and it had like all the
comedians that were friends with david
spade
um rob schneider so many interesting
cameos it was like
uh um david arquette
uh gary chandling was in it so it's this
really
fun crazy silly video um
and then i on the album
we did a 23 city tour the album went
double platinum it was like one of the
biggest
sandler albums so it was a good little
run where i literally came for two weeks
and that
a bag of clothes for two weeks and i
didn't stop working i got an editing
system in our house i you know we had a
house in
beverly hills and i was like editing all
the videos myself
i'm like this is great it's like film
school again i'm like this guy i'm 20
28 something like that and i'm like i
can't believe i'm getting to like live
with my friends
shoot stuff people really seeing it edit
i'm like this is a dream come true
and then we did the 23 city tour like it
was a rock and roll tour with a bunch of
adam's comedy songs so like
the hanukkah song um he did a bunch of
other songs like the halloween
song um piece of [ __ ] car a lot of the
ones you know though like um the turkey
song for thanksgiving
and i did sort of very inexpensive um i
came up with the stage design it was an
outdoor drive-in movie
in the summer and it was like beach
balls and all this stuff and
and and i had the set designer from his
movies do the satin
and i had a screen and on the screen i
would do things like
there was a song about grandmothers so i
got a bunch of grandmother shot him on
green screen dancing with spatulas
and then i took like contact paper from
like you know like grandma contact paper
that you'd put in the kitchen oh yes
like really
corny pattern and i've green screened
them again i just like
it was like this weird it would be
inspired by like a pink floyd drug video
but it was just
silly comedy for stoners and then
the other thing is we had a skit that
like it was a super stoner skit there
well
there was a talking goat and the talking
goat
these forced owners come across this
talking goat and van nuys tied to the
back of the truck
and they're like oh [ __ ] the talking
goat and adam did the voices would go
like hey
hey guys uh why did you untie me i'm
kind of bored here and
i played the old man who used to beat
the goat and uh
and and so that skit was the most
popular one
and um i was like oh i gotta film a goat
for the concert because the kids love it
when i say kids they're like 20
something year olds and we're 30
at the time and uh so the goat opens up
this show and people go nuts and then i
bring him back a few times
and newline had seen the show and they
were like we want to do a talking goat
movie
and and uh and we're like oh that's cool
but like we were thinking of doing
another movie though and then we pitched
them
i wanted to do a movie that was an 80s
movie and adam
and tim had come up with an idea for a
wedding singer who gets
tilted and has to perform weddings after
he got his heart broken
and then i said adam let's make that 80s
because then you can sing songs it won't
look like you're trying to be cool
it'll be a little retro it'll take the
curse off and he's like great and then
we pitched that and
it's funny because it was 1995
96 we're pitching an 80s movie and
people like 80s
that was six years ago and like you know
trust me like we just different
like i had the same clothes from six
years ago i'm like trust me no no
and then like sure enough i made i
learned my first
my first thing not to do in hollywood
when i was pitching the producer i go
think of how endazed and confused the
70s was a personality
and then the producer was like tasting
confused made like
10 million dollars why would you
reference that movie and i'm like no no
just how cool it was and i'm like oh i
get it you just gotta reference movies
when you want to get money you have to
reference movies that make a lot of
money
okay okay that's a good note it didn't
translate i was like no it's how cool
all right i get it it's like the titanic
no that was not yet
so anyway so we pitched that and they
loved the idea
and then we had we kind of worked on a
script and then
carrie fisher um newline hired her to
spend time on the script because she was
such the
the script doctor for romantic movies
and i got to spend
just got to la you know with my gym bag
i'd only been there for a few months
and next day i know i'm at carrie
fisher's house um
i'd have to go to her house every day
when she was writing she would literally
lay in bed and write
she would watch tv she'd be like let's
watch old movies and then i'd literally
be laying in bed with carrie fishing
i can't believe i'm in bed with princess
leia not you know just working not
nothing and uh and yeah we watched these
old movies and she showed me all these
great
oh you know we're old romantic comedies
um
roman holiday like you name them um
breakfast at tiffany's and then we would
write and uh
and it was great and we got to make this
amazing story and
and then drew signed on and um
before you know it i'm like awesome i'm
like wow i came i still have not gone
home i slept this bag of clothes
and i'm directing the wedding singer and
uh and uh
i remember the first day pulling up on
sunset the house we shot was the old
lady with the meatballs
rosie and uh it's first time driving the
set right i'm driving my little rental
honda civic
and i'm like why are these trucks here
i'm like i'm used to making a student
film we had one truck
it was like truck after truck and it's a
low budget movie it's like a 10 million
movie i was so intimidated by the time i
walked to set
that there was all this equipment i'm
like i need some dolly track and a
camera i didn't know you
need all this and uh yeah but i jumped
right in and
and i just did what i knew how to do and
and i realized oh
now i have a lot of crew when you change
things it just happens fast
and uh yeah and when we made that movie
we had no idea
it was gonna hit like it was a little
low-budget movie
and um it just blew up in a whole
different way and then i thought
now i'm [ __ ] because now i can't make
all those little weird movies
why because you thought now you're going
to be pigeonholed
yeah yeah and i was like i kind of want
to make and then
actually the funny thing was we adam's
like come on we're on the roll let's do
the water boy
so the wedding singer didn't even open
we made the water boy
uh and so in the middle of doing the
water boy the wedding singer opened
we flew home for the premiere and i was
like wow this is great now we
now there's no pressure on the water boy
like they gave us more money and time we
didn't feel like you know when you're
making a movie of a gun to your head
with budget um and uh yeah
but i did find it for a long time i was
pigeonholed i had so many little movies
i wanted to do
and i'd be willing to do them for no
money and
it was uh once they put you in that box
in hollywood it's hard
and i didn't know enough about how the
business works
to figure out how to make the little
movie it literally took me
10 movies till i got to make another
little indie you know and i've
all along i've been wanting to you know
and the movie i just made now how there
took like seven years to get that
together the little ones are really hard
to get
going just because you know it's always
talent driven you know so you have to
find a piece of talent that wants to do
it
how did you get clearance for all of the
songs in the wedding scene
i think well platinum
soundtrack by the way and they were
really easy because
most of them were one-hit wonders so
they cost you know i don't know what
songs cost but they would cost like five
grand there is um
uh um jersey
greatest uh bon jovi bruce bruce oh
bruce okay
the bruce springsteen song you know and
like um
250 000 for that song oh wow i mean when
you when you go for the classics
right they're 250. but all like things
like white wedding and
and especially some of the ones you
haven't heard since then there were one
even more one-hit wonders
yeah they're like 5 000 a song which
relatively
cheap um at the time so
um yeah it was a really lucrative
soundtrack but i didn't have a piece of
that that was my first movie
but uh i have a platinum record on my
wall it's so cool
did you all work together in terms of
what songs you really like like
video killed the radio star yeah you
know
um uh i was an 80s new wave kid so i had
all the music
um the adam had his
you know we both grew up on the same
music it's funny he went a little more
i went more edgy and he went a little
more commercial and we did
the one thing we all often battle on is
music and then in hindsight i look back
and i'm like it's a perfect balance that
if it was all me it would go too edgy
and if it was all him you know like so
like the song that i remember there was
a
holo note song and i was like i want
haircut 100 that was more 80s
and and you know now when i watch it
people love the holland
song so um but like the cure all that
stuff
that was me i was like new wave like
blonde hair shaved
i was that kid so i was like was i yeah
yeah
um yeah no susie song in there no no
susan the branches i know
and we wanted prince to open with 1999
but he wouldn't give any rights away
and also when dubs cry was supposed to
be in the in the club scene but
um david bowie said yes to um china girl
which was a real
that's great yeah that was [ __ ] cool
either i mean
prince david bowie win win
they're both none of this earth yeah
they're both beyond yeah
best part of them yes
what did making a movie teach you about
filmmaking and the business
what did making a movie yeah and it
could have been your first movie
could have been subsequent movies when
did you finally feel like it clicked for
you like oh
this is the movie making business this
isn't just oh you mean
the word you're talking about the word
business yeah well i i think
when i pitched the wedding singer and i
referenced um
the fact that it's going to be like
dazed and confused and the producer said
daisy confused made like 10 million
dollars why would you reference that
that's when i realized that when you're
trying to get a movie made
it's all about the box office in in in
the hollywood world um
you know at the end of the day it's an
investment for somebody and and they
and they want to make sure they make a
lot of money so um
you start to become aware that you have
to let people feel confident that the
movie has commercial appeal
in in that world and that's part of the
reason i
enjoy now delving into doing indies
because you know you can
have less pressure on that and more
pressure on just telling a great story
and
you're you do it for not a lot of money
with the
freedom to have creative control to make
something more specific that you want to
do
um but i would love to have paul thomas
you know paul thomas anderson's career
where he gets a lot of money to do
whatever he wants
[Laughter]
but the one thing i think i learned from
making more commercial movies is
i try not to get up my own ass as far as
like
i see younger filmmakers or i see
filmmakers that never had to do
commercial films and
they sort of can start to make every
moment drawn out
and what happens if you draw everything
out and make everything important
then everything's not important it's
like i think i've
learned from making commercial movies to
not waste people's time like let things
breathe when they have to but don't
like be like everything's great but
because you really can punctuate
the things you want by telling the story
more succinctly until it's that time
that it needs to breathe
so i am kind of glad the way my career
has gone that
i did my first nd i've done a bunch of
wider appeal movies and now
like when i made this movie how there i
didn't have many days i had 20 days to
shoot it in manhattan
um i didn't have the size crew or
anything it's even like smaller than a
tv crew i'd have like
three grips three calfers i'm really
decisive
um so i'm able to be much more you kind
of know what you want
um i was saying before students like
when you fake your first film
what you want and what you get are so
different and that's the painful process
of the first time you make a movie
and the one thing that after time like
what i have in my head
i can get much closer i mean there's a
lot of variables involved
but what i have in my head is a lot
easier to get really close
uh so when i get in the editing room i
already know what i want
um it it feels good it feels good
and i almost think it's great that i'm
doing hopefully going to be doing more
indies now because
i can just make them much more efficient
than it was my first or second film
so when you looked at the footage for
murdered innocents
was it a shock to you because you
thought you were getting one thing
and it didn't turn out that way it was
by the time i made murder
since i had made enough short films and
even
travel i i looked through the lens and
edited stuff enough that
uh my skill set wasn't as good as now um
i learned a lot like editing took that
movie took
a lot longer than you know i had to do
this movie now how there and
i edited it in like three and a half
months and my editor
you know i while i'm shooting i see cut
and i can give a million notes and
like i know what i want i'm not afraid
to experiment but you get all the stuff
the way you want then you get time to
experiment so
um yeah you just get better at knowing
what you want you get better at knowing
how things are gonna feel
um you get better it's like another
reality of the movie and
i have a more vivid image of that
reality
that being said though i always say like
people make their best films
when they first start making films and
probably towards the end of their career
somebody else said that it's like when
you're really young you make films
because you're just
daring and you don't care and then when
you're older you're wiser so
there's something to be said about both
ends of the spectrum
interesting so in the middle you think
people are too busy
making something and they're too worried
because is this going to get me my next
job
i'm not sure of that i hope i'm good in
the middle too
okay but every movie from the first one
to
everyone they do i don't know who has
the career where they know they're
definitely getting a movie
maybe scorsese and spielberg and um
you know even scorsese has to tussle a
little bit but
the good thing about being him is he can
ask leo or
any great actor to be in his movie and
they're going to say yes so
well that was part of the beauty of once
upon a time in hollywood was that
even though this guy had what seemed
like success he was worried about
getting the next one yeah and
the other character brad pitt's
character was just you know
yeah i'm good yeah i'm good if i
hopefully i get something and
i'll go up on a roof and fix an but
i think that was the beauty that was
good that was the cool part of that a
great contrast
yeah but i always think i always think
about like scorsese and coppola were two
of my
favorite filmmakers since like you know
obviously apocalypse no coppola did
godfathers and and uh and so many more
and i'm like why is he not making films
does he not want to well i feel like
there was
a period of time where he did want to
make films and it wasn't that easy
or he didn't want to he didn't want to
deal with it and it's
just sad to me that the industry can be
very forgetful of some great
talents um and uh yeah it's not always
fair
[Laughter]
to someone the best george roy hill was
like one of my favorite filmmakers and
he did this thing and he did
uh the world according to the garp and
and and then
push cassidy and and somebody told me a
cab driver goes yeah
i drove troy roy hill is going a while
back he passed away
yeah he's a little guy who lives in a
little apartment and i'm thinking this
guy made some of my favorite movies and
he just kind of like
went away and just you know i'm sure he
would have made more movies and
i always get really sad i hope that's
not me ever
but in my head i'm like even if i have
to take my iphone out i'll make a movie
[Laughter]
do you think that's become because
people's tastes change it's not so much
that
ah we don't want you anymore it's just
the style
and the and the taste and the tone of
movies changes i don't know i i
i yeah they do but i think
i think a great filmmaker you know
unless they really lost
everything good about themselves if they
lost their soul but if they're still
a a good human being they have something
to say
it's not like you know unless they're
done doing it i can't imagine
a guy like george roy hill couldn't make
he probably didn't want to deal with
all the politics anymore i'm guessing
i'm projecting i have no idea
um so that's you know it's just sad
though that
that i do think it's not fair like what
i wish coppola how cool would be if
coppola came out with another film
[Laughter]
we also now he has his winery yeah yeah
yeah
you can have a winery and make movies
that's true i don't think he's squeezing
the grapes
but even with a one-hit wonder you
always think
is it because they couldn't get another
i mean
even remember the ban yaz right allison
moyet
amazing boys and they're not one-hit
wonders but for a long time
they went away yeah you know you didn't
hear about them so
is it because someone gives up on the
business or the business doesn't want
them
yeah i know sometimes people are too
difficult like there's a film
that i loved called human traffic and it
was a british director and it was about
like
the whole like kind of ecstasy club
scene
and it was like i saw it and anybody
that saw it it was very small audience
saw it that i know
it's just like a really heartfelt coming
of age but very hip
cool movie because it dealt with like
ecstasy and kids doing drugs
but like in the heart of the movie was
really really good and
i couldn't wait to see what that
director would do next and nothing i
keep everyone's all checking and
and i don't think he's done anything and
i don't know
you know making a movie you have to be a
lot of things you have to be a filmmaker
you have to be a therapist and i think
you have to be a politician
and that's a hard part for a lot of
people um and
the politics are my least favorite part
of it because you get really
distracted and frustrated and um
but you know i just really want to make
films so i'm willing to do what i have
to do when it comes to
you know and i try to do from a positive
place you know i'm not
arrogant seems to work too for directors
that's just i don't function in that
place so
i think it's easier though for some of
those guys it seems like you just like
to laugh
and that's great got me this far why
should i stop now
what makes a great story great story i
think has to be honest
and that's a weird thing to say because
it could be fictional um but when i say
honest it needs to
be honest
it needs to you know it needs to have um
a theme that that that you believe
you as a filmmaker you want to tell a
story
that is something that you believe i
think it was scorsese was saying make it
personal
to tell a personal story and i've had to
come in different ways because i've had
more commercial films uh come at me so
it's not that i generated the idea
sometimes but
um i have to make it personal you know
the wedding singer i had my heart broken
a million times
i i applied things that i knew i knew
you know just when
your heart's broken you know and you
meet a new girl
your ex comes back in a black dress like
i think it's
a great story is is honest and it's
truthful
and um emotional honesty for me too and
the storytelling is important when i
read a script
i have to believe that the character
will do a certain thing
because the minute the character doesn't
do what an audience
um would do it
it loses the audio even if they don't
consciously take it in
it's when people start to get distance
but to relate to the character and he
makes choices
and then you get into movies and you get
you get situations where you're like
i'll use the wedding scene for example
in the script
he um
the julia drew's character
her boyfriend has to admit to
adam's character robbie hart that he
cheats on
her and i'm like okay well when would
a guy ever tell the best friend
guy friend that he cheats on her so i'm
like how could we make this work because
it's obviously a high drama point in the
story and it makes the rest of the story
be told really well so when we
reconstructed the scene and when i
directed
in the writing i thought well how do you
get this guy you play into his ego
and so in that scene now if you remember
but um adam notices
glenn glooly checks out the hot waitress
when she bends over
and he's like all right this guy's not
on the level this guy's
that's not cool if he's about he's not
in love with my best friend that i'm
falling in love with and uh he goes oh
yeah yeah we used to get girls like that
and then and then and he's like uh uh
adam's character says something like 10
years ago
yeah probably 10 years ago and then like
glenn golia says yeah tried ten days ago
and like he baits him in and it's all
ego and it's believable
and and so when i read a script the
emotional honesty is everybody has to do
things that you believe
so sometimes if you're boxed into a plot
turn you have to make sure
it works for everyone you have to make
sure you sell it and that you would
believe
and when you watch that scene you're
like that guy would would fall for the
bait and then he you know goes on and on
and tells us about how he cheats on his
wife in the city and and you don't
question it and
and and so yeah a a a
uh what's the original question how do
you tell what's a good story it has to
be honest and true
and and and and meaningful and sometimes
it's the simplest story
love is good but you see a movie to
experience
love is good you know and sometimes it's
a more complex
um you know emotion i did click and it
was about you know fast-forwarding
through your life and
and and you you kind of he wishes his
way through all the [ __ ] of life
and and and the theme of the movie is
like life is what happens when you're
living it it's like you shouldn't
speed through it so um it's nice to just
have
relatable it's nice when the story's
relatable um to the most part
i think and and and and just to be
honest
john lennon i think is yeah life is what
happens while you're making other plans
yeah okay yeah i like quoting great
people
yeah i think someone had a bumper
sticker
one of my other favorite quotes is um uh
you don't fail until you stop trying
einstein oh okay that's a good one oh
he's got me this far so
i'm gonna go with einstein and john yeah
that's a good one
how do you direct a great scene like
what are you looking for
what has to happen i how do i direct a
great scene
that's not a fair question you kind of
direct
every scene as best you can um
and then you know and then sometimes
there's moments where you go like wow
this could be the best scene in the
movie
um so i don't know if you you just try
to service
the story the best you can so
so some movies like i feel like you want
the hand of the director to push you
around and push the camera and move the
camera
and other movies you wanna you know
romantic comedy like um
wedding singer i wanted to just step
back and
not feel the director's hand so in that
movie i used colors
to tell a story um uh adam goes from
like um when he's happy blue
when he gets his his heart broken the
camera dollies and you see red brick
behind him from that point on
he's in all maroons and reds because
he's heartbroken
um he has like his worst part is he goes
to a
red wedding it's italian silver black
garish and he has the love stink scene
he freaks out
and then he still has the broken heart
of his
ex but then he's starting to meet julia
who's happiness again
and in the bar mitzvah it's all blue he
still has his red jacket
they bond over the little girl and he
takes off his red jacket because he
finally
loses the other girl his broken heart
um so that was done in a way that you
didn't feel the director doing it but
subconsciously
it's there um other movies i like flying
the camera around
and like you know click there's canted
angles and um you just try to service
every scene the best you can in um
hot air the indie i just did i'd never
broke on the fourth wall
and um part of the goal of the movie was
to make
not pick sides and then at some point i
thought well the next level is
no not we're not picking right being
wrong or left is wrong
but i wanted everyone in the audience to
feel
guilty for where we're at and um
i there's a speech that was in the movie
where steve has almost like a network
moment where he breaks down
and snaps on everyone and uh the writer
i said make sure we hit everyone like
facebook and
and instagram and their phones and and
he wrote this brilliant speech
and um and when i shot it it was just
sort of happening and i was like oh this
is gonna be great we'd even jump cuts
and
and i'm like we got to break the fourth
wall and the very end of the movie
steve looks down the lens and says the
american dream is dead and buried and
you're dancing on its grave and i was
like
this is one of my i never broke the
fourth wall i'm like i waited for the
right moment
and uh so it wasn't it's like
you just try to direct every scene the
best you can and then it just sort of
you know it happens sometimes where you
feel like that was pretty
good do you storyboard i shot list
and then if there's visual effects or
it's complicated i storyboard because
just time constraints it's you know but
i literally
shotless and my goal my thing is you
shot listener movie in order
because you read it and you shot listen
because you
can evolve lenses and do stuff i i
whenever i hear a director shows up that
day and decides what lenses and i
thought
if you're not you're shooting an order
you're not making a you're not telling a
real story
you're just like to me a movie is a
vision from beginning to end so i'll
i'll say in the beginning let's start on
wide lenses so we're close and intimate
but then
you know like things like that you need
to progressively do so you need to plan
it ahead of time so you know
when you shoot day 31 we're on the tight
lenses we're not on the white or the
color
or you know a shirt should be red so you
have to plan
all that stuff out in order and that's
just discipline and
sometimes i think only like 10 percent
of the directors really do
the job right like that and and and i
think it shows
like the people that are great are great
per reason just takes work
now the color thing came into play it's
funny my first movie murdered innocence
i
literally had like um you know it was
like again it was like the guy had to be
this guy and that guy
the guy was just like construction guy
so i didn't have like a designer
and we were just using locations and
then i had seen
billy madison um with sandler and i'm
like
man the production design it was first i
was like it's amazing
and i'm like i want that guy and and
this perry blake who's done almost all
my movies because i was like that guy's
great and
we hit it off because the first move we
did was wedding singing i'm like i want
to tell a story with colors
not camera moves and so on every movie
like
it's all about like in in click it was
he he talked me into doing the movies
like you get to create the future and
i'm like
oh yeah and then i was like oh wait the
story is great we're like one part of
the future everything's angular and then
the next cause we have a bunch of time
jumps
the later part everything's round again
and and just
and just even in like storytelling
colors like what
here comes the boom with kevin james he
starts out as a horrible person that's
just selfish and
it's the winter and we made the color
like we pulled all the saturation i made
it really cool
felt like the fighter the movie the fire
yeah and then as he blossoms as a human
being as a teacher and he starts
teaching his kids and
you know we got more and more colorful
and i added color adding color to the
set
and then we actually did it so the
seasons changed too i timed the movie
out so we're shooting
an outdoor scene when the trees were
blossoming and then
it ends in vegas which is like full
spectacle of color so if you see
real one it looks like the fighter and
you see the last reel you'd be like how
are those the same movie
but if you progressively change a movie
as you go
it you won't it'll just happen without
you being jarred
um but yeah i love using color to tell
tell a story but that was
from getting a production designer and
and wardrobe too you start to realize
the wedding singing everybody's like
color coded same thing in ridiculous six
each western town had like a color
palette that and and everybody
it's really it really gets tricky when
it gets to be hundreds of extras
you need a really good costume designer
and you need the dp your costume
designer and production designer
all on the same page that's the thing
that i love about doing bigger budget
movies
because you have just more control over
everything
and uh and it's funny after i did the
india i had the best time because i had
nobody tell me what i could what i
should and shouldn't do and
it was literally my final cut and then i
was like man i'm really itching to do a
big ruby again
and i'm back now i'm my next movie's
going to be the legend of sinbad
so i'm back into that world but then i'm
like oh with that comes all the politics
too
so it's you know it's always a give and
take
well in the 80s was so colorful even
thinking back to like designing women
you know they all had the great outfits
and the shoulder pads and it was so
colorful
yeah and you know it was to me the color
palette in that movie
i was like everything in the 80s felt
man-made
it was like the 50s too like so i was
like no 70s calls no browns no green
everything was like fuchsia and purple
and electric blue
and because that's that's my image of of
the 80s all of a sudden we were making
everything and everything
everybody's haircuts were cut right
people wouldn't have beards and like you
know
if they did it would be like more
trimmed yeah i mean
colored stone washed jeans yeah purple
and
turquoise yeah everything felt like
those whole
people did stuff to everything it didn't
just grow out of the ground
five things the director should never do
on set
look distracted when they're talking to
their actors
um that's one of the things you have to
do you have to make sure you're always
put on a good face for your actors
because they're looking at you they're
they're putting themselves out there and
you have to be there for them
so you always have to react respond
and be positive even if you have a note
it should come from a positive place so
never be negative to your actors
uh that's only one huh
four more to go um
only get angry when you're really angry
because i hardly ever ever ever ever get
angry
about something but if i do it works
nobody wants to see me upset they're
like wait you know
and that's usually like behind the
scenes not in front of people but like
you know if you're
having a dispute with the studio or
producer or something
um that's two what else should you do
obvious now hit on women
or men yeah or men sorry
in any physical way and that's always
been ingrained in me like you're in the
position of power
i i you know that's always been my rule
before the me too thing is
just don't do that just common sense um
uh that's three well yeah that's another
one i would say if you have to even
think about if a joke is appropriate
then you shouldn't say it
you have to even contemplate it so
that's four okay okay
darn that takes away all the best jokes
and then the fifth one what not to do as
a director don't be late
my god and don't ever be unprepared
like you just over prepare you could
throw the plan out
but you have to be prepared it's like
that's
you have a ticking clock from the minute
you get there
and so if you're not decisive and and
didn't do your homework
you're just burning money it doesn't end
up on the screen
so six things six one the joke one
i still tell jokes
[Laughter]
who brought hot air to you my manager
ali e tree at 360 at the time uh
said hey this is really good script you
should read and it was on my desk
and i i'm the worst in reading scripts i
just take forever because i
direct them while i'm reading them and
my producing partner amy keene who's
done the last seven movies or so with me
um was like what's on your desk that you
haven't read and i said
it's over there and she read it and goes
oh my god you've been talking about this
topic
about how polarized we are this is like
an amazing little movie
about a girl who comes into a rat i'm
like really and we read it
like oh my god we have to get this paid
so it was literally
my manager to my producing partner who's
smarter than me
especially at reading are you a consumer
of the
heavy consumer of a tv news yes
you are oh yeah it gets me depressed it
does yeah i notice that you really can
start to
i've had to like turn stuff i escape it
and and it's nice to escape it and
and uh especially all the headlines just
are geared to get you upset
but we're in a time now where so many
things are upsetting you know whether
it's a another school shooting
or you know the president just
disregarding the respect for his office
or disregarding the justice department
or
or just doing things that i just think
are
i was always taught were wrong like
wrong
thing wrong being okay is not okay with
me
and it is upsetting but yeah i have to
turn it off though
and and check out and breathe and look
at the stars and look at the air and you
know but then i start worrying about
climate change right entrails
i'm like that's this that supersedes
everything like like once the planet's
gone
i had this really depressing thought
because i thought part of you make
movies you're like yeah
i kind of want to be immortal long after
i'm gone my movies will play
and um i started thinking well if the
earth
has like an ice age or it burns up i'm
like oh i got all the arts gone i'm like
van gogh i'm like everything da vinci
like
so there's a lot more than our lives at
stake it's like everything that's been
created for
you know the last thousand years is
gonna be gone
so i think it's a high priority uh
making sure
like what climate change like why don't
we just play it safe
like even if we're over over playing our
hand like i think we're better off and
obviously we're not over playing our
hand by trying to get off carbon and
stuff like that but it's like
wouldn't that be the smart safe thing to
do
when you read the script did you want
any changes to it
did you want to embellish any parts yeah
well when i first read the about how
there when i read the hot air
it was pre um trump era and it's funny
because we're trying to get made and
at some point i'm like wow trump's gonna
be present let's read it again and all
of a sudden the shock
value because steve coogan's character
lying on the right wing talk shows
says stuff like let's build a wall now
let's build a moat like send
them back that kind of thing and i'm
like oh wow i lost the shock value but
i'm like
but it's even more necessary that
this is becoming accepted so um
uh what did we change the biggest thing
we changed
there is a part in the movie where he
does something atrocious
and in the original draft of the script
he sort of loses his career
and i thought we got to reflect the now
and then now as his career would go that
way
and so we changed that and the other big
change
two other big changes was um
the speech that he did when he goes off
the rails
it now like i said before he i wanted to
make the movie not just be left right
i wanted to be as unbiased as possible
but i wanted everyone in the chairs in
the theater
to also feel responsible so i sort of
had um will was a brilliant writer write
a speech that
kind of incriminates everyone for how
polarized we are
um you know talking about um
you know tweeting about you know
kids in syria but then also buying yoga
pants from a sweatshop in bangladesh
like making us all feel like
we're all hypocrites and let's all try
to be better um
and then the other thing steve did a bro
steve's brilliant by the way as a
producer writer
um he has a big speech at the end
um and when he's i don't want to give
too much of the plot away but it's
it's kind of a healing speech and steve
wrote a lot of the bits or gave little
bits for the writer to
to to um say and
he really brought some really heartfelt
stuff um
that the writer was able to put in even
to the point where he quotes obama
saying
we can disagree without being
disagreeable and steve's like i know
it's an obama quote you're going to call
me on that but
you know it's just he found a way to
make a real nice
balance to a character when i first read
the script the biggest challenge was
how do we make this guy who's spewing
this stuff likable by the end
and and he manages to be likable i think
and and not like he has to turn into a
liberal or
you know he stays with his views but now
he's approaches it from a better
a more a with a place of more integrity
what are some tips to directors who are
working with a-list talent for the first
time
well generally with actors you just have
to remember
they're putting themselves out there
they're exposing yourself the first time
i was on a set
i was so preoccupied worried about the
camera and all this other stuff and
my producer was jack carpenter my
roommate at the time was like
you gotta tell tell them they were good
tell them they were great i'm like
and i've never looked back from that
since um
so in general actors have to be coddled
and told
how they're doing and you have to put
all your attention to them
with an a-list actor even more so it's
like
they're they're putting themselves out
there and and you just have to
be attentive when when when a take ends
it's like
be ready to give them response they're
professionals
and you have to be professional and your
job is to give them feedback
um so it's easy to be distracted
especially if it's like your first movie
because you have so much going on in
your head and i'm sure a really good
actor will realize that but
you're gonna get a lot better
performance out of your actors if you're
there
for them right after with the thought
compliment them on what's good
and then tell them what you want to try
different i usually don't go that wasn't
good i would usually say that was good
let's try one that's more this you know
or
you know um and with an a-list actor if
they say they want to try
something that you don't want them to do
i think
you should probably let them have their
take and not make it feel like
all right you could do yours but i'm
never going to use it you'll be like
okay cool yeah try one you're like so
it's just about being
positive and and being there every step
of the way and letting them know that
you're
super focused on them um when they're
doing their thing
have you always been a people person you
seem like you just kind of know you have
like a high emotional yeah i've
definitely been a people person
i also think i'm pretty in tune i think
i'm
sensitive to people i could sit and
watch people and i think it's part
what's good about directing because a
lot of subtle things people do
i watch like a couple sitting on the
couch and i'm just poured somewhere and
i'll be like
okay she's mad at them about something
he did okay no no
and i can kind of just read body
language pretty good
uh and i guess in that way i can sense
when somebody's
upset and it's he's it's pretty easy for
me to
to turn things around by just being
sensitive to people i mean i'm sure i'm
not
i miss stuff i don't want to be so
that's the other thing don't be so full
of yourself that you think you always
know the right thing
it's a combination of the both but yeah
i definitely had that gift somehow
do you think it's also coming from a
large family where you were around i
mean you have a lot of brothers and
sisters
i definitely a lot of brothers sorry i
have three sisters
i'm the baby i'm sure that's part of it
um italian family very emotional
everybody doesn't hold back we
stab from the front not the back like
you said about new yorkers
um but yeah everybody says it like it is
um
i was always pretty sensitive i cried
pretty easily
um so i think that
sensitivity is just part i mean i feel
like sometimes
like everything i became was to become a
filmmaker
i like to think that way i'm like if i
was born in a different era i'm not sure
what i would be doing
because the technology needed in
filmmaking and it all
it all fits together for what i'm good
at i think
we kind of touched on this earlier but
how have your expectations
of the business change since going to
nyu tisch
being a filmmaker this sort of journey
that you've had
how have your expectations of making
films and pleasing the audience
changed i i the whole process of
making films and has
kind of been what i thought i know would
always be challenging i think
you have this idea that once i think
anybody in any career
especially in entertainment there's
never like i made it
there's always gonna be more challenges
like you're always scrapping to get your
next movie
you always set the bar higher you don't
want to do more of what you did so
i think the one thing that surprised me
that you're always
working hard to get your next movie um
and the other part that i think
i think is a weird thing that's gotten
worse
i think it goes back to the internet i
don't think
film critics should be film critics i
think they should be film enthusiasts
and i don't think um
the setup of the job right now is they
feel like they have to critique and say
what's wrong
i think we'd all benefit more
if it was a film enthusiast and they
would look for films
that you need to see because all the
ones that are
popular and commercial honestly i don't
even look at the tomato rating my movies
don't always get reviewed very well
people seem to be they don't like adam
or they do like adam
that doesn't help um i look at the
audience um
response if anything you know i'd rather
call somebody i know that saw the movie
but i i i think the audience is leaving
theaters saying what they thought
is a more accurate gauge if a movie's
good i think
um it's weird how critics will feel like
there's certain movies they have to like
and they don't like and
and and if if they weren't critics and
their film enthusiasts
their job would be great because they
would list a bunch of movies that we all
need to see
right now there's probably 10 movies
that aren't going to get a whole lot of
press
and they're probably really some good
ones and i would rather read the article
like oh [ __ ] i'm gonna go see that movie
because i
i that that filmmaker would never get
seen so i just wish it was more like
that when you go back to the
there's a kaiju cinema it was uh was um
truffaut and yadara the new wave they
all had they were filmmakers reviewing
other movies and it was much more
about embracing what they liked and less
about
taking pop shots at you know if you
don't like a movie too i also think if i
was a reviewer
i'd be like look if you like action
movies that do this this and this you're
going to be happy
but i think reviews are just generally
are just
just you know trying to cut it down or
just
they just decided okay we're gonna like
this movie and and say we like this
movie
you know it's funny like when the water
boy came out
they talked about how sophomoric it was
and how there were so many fart jokes
and i was like there's not a fart joke
in the water boy you can say it's
sophomoric
that's not your opinion and and at the
time um
the farrelly brothers had did the um
kingpin
and and they embraced it which was
really funny great movie
but i mean that one had fisting bulls
and like they had full-on [ __ ]
so it's like the the it's not an honest
um you know nobody's from it's not an
honest uh
system so i i think there should be film
enthusiasts
so when you ask me about the filmmaking
that's one of the things
that that disappoints me and um yeah and
that and that you have to always fight
to get your next movie or work really
hard to get the next one
do you think the same way with social
media and we're outing people and we're
putting our thoughts out there there's a
power in trying to take things down
there's definitely a negativity um that
that seems to
excel um and and and i don't know how we
have to reinvent it but
i guess it starts with each and every
person and you know listen as an artist
that's what i'm gonna
try to make people as long as you have
integrity as long as you're
everything that goes back to integrity
if you have integrity you're not gonna
take a pop shot at somebody and you're
gonna give a balanced argument or
i don't like this for this reason but
you might like it you know if you're
more
if people more fair i think we'll be
okay
um it's that lack of of seeing the
person's face that you're
you're picking on that the internet does
that
that causes it you know louis c.k did
the whole thing about how
he doesn't want his kids to have a phone
because when you're a kid
your tendency is to punch a kid in the
face and then the kid starts crying and
then you realize oh i feel bad and then
you form empathy but on
a phone you punch a kid in the face by
saying something mean but you never get
that response so
it's that lack of of being able to form
empathy
that that's that's missing with the
internet i don't want to take technology
away
i just want us to elevate ourselves to
be better people to be able to handle
our toys
do you think most film critics should
have gone to film school yeah i'm not
sure the background i haven't done
research
i don't want to sound like i feel like a
lot of them went to film someone that
they just
didn't apply themselves to make movies
and so there's a frustration i
i'm not everybody there's some people
that just love films and
and but the feeling i get you know is
that
you know sometimes i'll write back to a
film critic and they're very not angry
i'll always be like oh
there's somebody who wrote something
about um blended
and and i was like well my intentions
weren't that i
in a very straightforward way i was like
i tried to make something that wasn't
typical i wanted to make two people
falling in love over parenthood
not and then the guy wrote back like i
forgot the directors of human beings
it was such a great feeling i was like
because i'm like i felt really bad
because blended by the way
people love that movie kids love that
movie and the
it was one of the few times that the
critics they don't usually bother me
but there's three amazing kids in that
movie that are
more there's one two three there's five
kids in the movie and they
loved the movie they loved making it and
they loved the premiere and they saw the
people laughing and loving the movie
and they couldn't wait for the reviews
and i was thinking oh these poor kids
are gonna get their hearts crushed and
and they did and they were just like
they couldn't believe that the movie got
shredded you know
uh to pieces and i feel like why not
wake up around tomatoes but probably
like
15 or something and uh it's not fair
like that movie is not if you i don't
care what you say that movie compared to
a bunch of other movies that got
higher ratings it was it delivered on
what it was supposed to do and
so it bugs me when like people that are
critics are just so easy to be like [ __ ]
that this movie's
predictable and this is that and that
you know that kind of thing but even the
great critics do it if um
siskel and eber is really funny if you
go back to um
the waterboy interview that might be
online um
ebert was like
he kind of gave it like a like this
movie was
not great it was sophomoric and then
siskel goes
i can't believe you and i go oh my god
he's going to like the movie
he goes how did you even watch it and i
thought well that just says exactly
what's wrong
like you can't say that you can't go in
that
bias wow so
it's not always fair but i i for me what
matters is how people feel
and the ultimate um
[Music]
validation for me is my movies are on tv
for 20 years
and they run over and over and over and
uh and i can't say that about a lot of
the other movies
that came out those years so that that
that would i and then in the long run
that's what i
that's what matters i'm like i don't
know i can't guarantee a movie's gonna
get reviewed well i can't even guarantee
it's gonna
you know make a lot of money i just know
i'm gonna make a movie that's gonna be
emotionally honest it's gonna be a story
that i think is important
and it will probably have a shelf life
it's a wonderful life was the reason i
wanted to make movies and my parents
were you know they're in their 80s so
they're like oh my god that movie
bombed when it came out because it was
depressing it came out after the war
and i think oh my god this is like the
classic of all classics and
i was like i always go to that like oh
good the movies don't have to do well
when they come out they have to do well
over time and that's the true test
once you say yes to directing a movie
what are some of the first
few steps you're taking well you've read
the script
so usually the first thing is let's now
make the script better
yeah usually you want to get the script
firing on all cylinders
um meanwhile you're trying to put the
best cast together
um it always starts there and then once
it comes to the film
i can't wait to start to visualize and
shot list what the movie is and you
really can't do that until your location
scout
because that sort of determines what
your shots are going to be a little bit
um so i just that's those are the first
pro and you know obvious things you
start to
you either know a dp that's perfect or
you start interviewing dps
um uh certain roles like like you know
you know you're gonna use your editor
and stuff like that um
but what i learned about um a movie is
it's like
it starts to have its own soul so
when creatively you're trying to figure
out like what color do we paint the wall
it's what's cool about a movie is it
starts to answer itself
like you look into the soul of the movie
and you go that's what it should be
um so i i get excited when it starts to
kind of become its own you know
thing i haven't had kids and everybody's
like you know you haven't had kids
they're like well right now
i've had movies and they've been my kids
so i do feel like they take on their own
life um so it's about you know letting
it
start to become what it's supposed to be
it's a it sounds very esoteric but
that is pretty much part of the process
and and
as the pieces come together it starts to
i don't know if it was always there or
that
the you know was the soul of it there
and then you add on it
and it evolves or or does the soul
happen from all these
people being attached and involved but
um it's probably something
that that touches me inside
and then that's the thing i look at to
how do you cast it how do you bring
people together
how do you answer all these questions um
on how to best make
uh how to best tell the story and you
tend to use a lot of the same people
i definitely have um yeah yeah there's a
there's a
comfort but it's always nice too to like
once in a while bring in a different
production design because it
takes you out of your element and you
know but i i try to use the same
production designer same editor
um but through different reasons
scheduling this that it doesn't always
work out and you always like embrace
the the the fresh perspective so
yeah a little both but it's nice like i
like i hadn't worked with um larry
gilliard since the waterboy
and i watched he he he was the kicker in
the war boy and i watched his career
uh as he went on to the wire and done
such really good stuff and so happy for
him
he was always a good new york actor and
then when i was doing um
uh hot there i was like oh he'd be great
as the radio guy
so it's so much fun to have somebody
gone on their journey and come back now
with a whole new
set of talent yeah so a little both
what's been the easiest year for you as
a filmmaker and then what's been the
most difficult
easiest year for me as a
filmmaker
the easiest year a couple different
times
come to mind i think when i made around
the world
in 80 days it was
such an amazing joy
to have an international crew all my
trial like everything i
life had led up to that point i've
traveled the world i'd been to the great
wall i was like i know where we're gonna
film on the great wall
and to lead such a massive it was like i
don't know the crew was like
six eight hundred it was like we had
like 400 thai people
we had 100 british people we had um a
crew from germany to just be the leader
of that bigger of a group and to have
everyone
like i have people stopping on the
stream go that was the best time i ever
had
making a movie and it was almost like a
life experience to be in all those
places
and all those parts of the world with
all different languages and
you know we had one scene where um there
was
people spoke chinese thai
french we had all these translators all
this thing
and we shot this dinner scene i wanted
it all to take place
at at magic hour and so we were filming
in this chinese village that we built in
thailand
and at 4 30 we run up to the table
and and it was just pulling off like
amazing stuff because everybody was in
sync
and it was amazing that the challenge
was so many people which was everything
from
so many different parts of the world
that it was like that that to me was
like maybe
it wasn't easy in that it was the most
uh rewarding
and most difficult
i think it was right after doing the
wedding singer and the water boy and
having
massive success and trying to figure out
what i wanted to do and i was really
cautious
about what next career step i was trying
to make a smaller movie i was having a
hard time doing that
and it was it was odd because you would
think it'd be the easiest time in
somebody's life
but it was important for me not to just
just follow a path that everybody was
shoving down my throat
you know and and and like do this when
we get out moving
and uh and um i passed on a ton of great
movies
um just because i was like i don't know
if that's what i should do so it was
difficult to have that and feel like am
i blowing an opportunity and
and then i just had to take stock in
myself and say well i'm a good filmmaker
so let me just
capitalize on that do you think that's
something that
you don't hear much about in the
industry you always hear about how to
make it quote unquote
but nobody gives you the tools or or
information on what happens when you
actually reach this really high level
and everybody's patting on the back and
emails are coming in phone calls
yeah i think it's easy to you look at
how many people are
super famous and then they can't do
anything and
and and that's a sad story and a lot of
entertainment a lot of different
industries but mainly entertainment
and it's because everybody wants you to
cash in and do more of the same
and to me it was always important that i
get to make movies for my whole life so
i didn't want to like
just burn out and and and
just do what everybody wanted and uh
you know i probably could have made a
ton more money than i did
if i went that route but um
i'm really happy now and i'm making
little movies i'm going to make another
big movie
i you know who knows maybe i would be
doing bigger movies and little movies
anyway but i just have to
follow what i think is right i think
that's my advice to people
because it's easy to get sucked into
like everyone's going to want to make
you
especially when you have success
everyone's going to want you to cash in
and
cashing in could be good or it could be
bad you know it's like
it's all to yourself what you you kind
of know inside
what the right thing to do is and and if
you don't you shouldn't just do it
you should spend the time figuring it
out so go travel the world be on a
mountaintop in tibet
ask yourself yeah that's got to be very
difficult and i think a lot of people
think well
if i just reach that i won't have any
trouble it'll it'll be oh there's never
and the the one question i get asked all
the time was what was your big break i'm
like
there's never one big break there's a
bunch of little breaks and you have to
capitalize on them as much as you can
it's like
thank god i got into nyu i didn't even
you know realize my sats were a big deal
i was pretty smart
and uh if i didn't get to nyu i wouldn't
even realize you could make films or
maybe i would have found it another way
and then you know and then i got nyu and
my student film won some awards and uh
you know and then i got to do
a music video with adam sandler and then
that music video was really good then i
got the tutor and then
it's like it's never one break nobody
has one break no i don't care who it is
um there's never one break you just um
you just gotta capitalize on every one
of those breaks and sometimes you're
going to make a mistake
but and you got to pick yourself back up
and keep searching for that next
opportunity to do what you do